[Music]
well welcome everybody great to see you
we are lucky enough today to have David
Moore from Northwestern University here
joining us today to talk about his great
work that he's been doing on the
crossroads between behavior change
technology and serious mental health
David is one of the pioneers using
mobile technologies sensing platforms
and Suites of applications and really
studying their efficacy with real users
who have real problems over time he
weaves this technology into their
everyday lives which is what I really
appreciate about it and I'm gonna stop
there and let him tell you about that
except I forgot to say that he's also in
the School of Medicine at Northwestern
and he's the director of CBI T which
stands for the Center for behavioral
intervention technologies which is very
well known
so welcome David thank you thanks thanks
very very much it's really a pleasure to
be here to spend some time with Mary and
to get to know some of you so so thank
you thank you for inviting me out so I'm
gonna talk today about
I mean first I'll just give I don't know
how I'm a clinical psychologist by
training and you know I've collaborated
with people in HCI and computer science
and engineering enough to get myself
into trouble but that's not not not the
area that I know that much about so most
of this is going to be from the
perspective of a psychologist so start
off with just a few a few slides to kind
of set the framework in terms of
psychology then I'm going to talk a
little bit about kind of a new direction
that we have Mary already alluded to
that we call and telecare a platform of
applications and then talk a little bit
about sensing so and I have to mention
this so there's disclosures so I've had
consulting fees from oats going op them
and then I have an ownership interest in
actualised health which is trying to
commercialize some of the things that
we're talking about so mental health
most of what I'm going to focus on is
common mental health problems like
depression and anxiety but mental health
problems are common so around 20 to 25
percent of Americans will have a mental
health problem in any given
year you know and and the common ones
like mood disorders and anxiety
disorders you can see the the prevalence
rates there our workforce is is
inadequate so only around 20 percent
receive of Americans receive what's
called minimally adequate care and
believe me when you look at what
minimally adequate it is far more
minimal than adequate so and and so we
have and it's you know we have about
half the number of mental health
professionals that we would need to
treat people and we're never gonna have
enough people and even if we had them
most they wouldn't necessarily be where
the patients are so ninety ninety
million Americans live in federally
designated mental health professional
shortage areas higher than you know any
other medical medical specialty so this
is the you know those this is the
argument for digital mental health when
we think about treating people with
mental health problems behaviorally or
so with psychological treatments usually
there's some kind of we've we've tended
to use theories that were developed in
in for for psychotherapy and this is the
most this is one of the most common ones
there are a lot of them and and so this
this theory cognitive behavioral therapy
it's cognitive behavioral theory you
know starts from the premise that that
when people are experiencing emotional
disorders we can't reach inside like
with a pharmaceutical reach inside and
change that feeling but we can leverage
the fact that our thoughts and our
behaviors affect our and our feelings
are all affected right so if I if I came
in here and I was thinking these people
man they're really smart they're gonna
judge me really harshly I better do a
good job I would be nervous I would it
would it would affect my thoughts it
would make me feel nervous I might be
jittery and my behaviors right but if I
come in and think well you know they
might have some disagreements with what
I said what I say and we could get in
some interesting discussions my whole
approach my thoughts my feelings will be
different right so so so we usually
start with a theory I'm not sure that
that's a good idea that's what we've
done up until now but I just want to put
that out there the other thing I want to
talk about is some features of treatment
for for for mental health problems that
that we should keep in mind when we're
thinking about treating mental health so
is there slow you know it's not like you
take a pill and you get better
psychotherapy or pharmacotherapy takes
at least four weeks even to have the
first the first impact and and
psychotherapy is often take 8 to 20
weeks pharmacotherapy to get a full
response usually takes several months
and then people have to be on it so when
we think about digital mental health
we're not talking about people using an
app for a couple of days you know this
is something that needs to be sustained
over time it's challenging and it's hard
when people are depressed they don't
have any motivation to do anything they
feel like nothing's gonna help for
people with anxiety they become fearful
and they think oh this is not gonna work
this is not gonna work and so it's it's
hard to keep people on task and so if
you think about people using an app over
time these are gonna be really
challenging for you know to achieve that
and so what we end up with in
psychotherapies or in red treatments
generally is we have specific factors
like teaching people to monitor their
thoughts or their or teaching people to
change their behaviors those are kind of
the specific skills and then we have
what we call nonspecific factors like
empathy warmth installation of hope that
are common to all treatments that try to
keep people engaged okay so this is just
sort of features to keep in mind that
that that had from psychotherapy that
might be applicable so just a brief a
brief history of digital mental health
this start you know the people started
playing with this about 20 years ago as
the internet became ubiquitous and
people develop websites and the websites
the idea was to to take psychotherapy
and deliver it through a new medium and
so we they took some of the components
like in psychotherapy therapists teach
patients things right patients come in
they don't know some things the
therapists teach them things and so you
know some of the websites this is an old
website that we've taken down but you
know there's didactics by a video and
via you know via text a lot of forms of
psychotherapy have homework sort of
worksheets this is a common one for for
CBT and so
get instantiated in the websites and
then what happened is you know as we
started to build these things nobody
would use them so what we did was we put
coaches in to try to get people to stay
on board and and so there were
dashboards it kind of helped coaches
understand what the patients were doing
to help them keep people on board okay
so this is kind of this is kind of the
standard mental health you know digital
mental health and there are some people
doing more interesting things but if you
look at the commercial world this is
this is pretty much where we still are
we are I mean if you think about
Marshall McLuhan said you know that in
any new medium the first instance of
that new medium is imitating the old one
and that's what we've done here is we've
imitated the the old the the you know
the old medium of face-to-face
psychotherapy at least we've tried to so
we have and that's taken us a long way
there's been more than a hundred
randomized controlled trials now and
they've pretty consistently shown that
if you offer it just offer it without
any kind of support you get a minimal
effect it's not very big people tend not
to use it they tend not to stay engage
but if you add in a coach you get effect
sizes that start to look like
psychotherapy and they start to look
like pharmacotherapy so you get you can
get some pretty robust effect sizes and
your coaches don't need to be don't need
to be therapist yeah human coaches right
now right live and this is some usually
done with it's it can be done people
have done it with email messaging phone
calls sometimes more time sometimes less
so there's a lot of variability and in
terms of what that coaching is and I
will get to that but I think one of the
problems is we don't haven't really
defined what that is but but this said
we have a lot of big research database
and then when you look at implementation
as we've started talking to Kaiser
Permanente in large care systems around
the United States and indeed around the
world we see I have not seen yet one
single successful implementation inside
a care setting yet they may be out there
but I haven't seen it and and I've seen
a lot of failures and and so we have a
huge research to practice gap here which
is not uncommon in in
in in medicine but but I think that this
means that there's some you know some
fundamental problems in in how we've
approached this and there's there are
kind of a lot of them and we outlined
some of them in this paper here I'm
going to talk about two of them here one
is I think the design has been atrocious
and I'll talk about that in a moment and
then the other is we've ignored the
human side and I'm not talking about
here I'm not talking about putting apps
up on the App Store right that's
perfectly useful we've had we've had
self-help books for four decades in the
stores and people can get those but I'm
talking about designing systems or tools
that can be embedded in our healthcare
system which is where I think we're
gonna actually make an impact
so we've ignored the systems and the
human side of it so the design problems
beating the blues is one of the oldest
and and and and still I think it's still
commercially available and it's
basically 50-minute sessions
psycho-educational sessions it's each
CBT skills by a text and video it's not
badly designed but people you know when
when I look at when you see the
implementations people don't use it when
people are depressed they don't want to
go home and watch a video 50 minute
video every week you can't get people to
do it that's that I think is the problem
and there are you know others that maybe
this is an extreme example but a lot of
them have this kind of flavor to it so
we've developed products that people
don't use and then I think what we do is
we go out and we recruit 400 people from
the internet and we find the 400 people
who are willing to use the crap that we
built excuse my french and then we call
that the evidence so it's not surprising
that we can't you know we can't get the
the stuff to work in the real world the
developments been top-down it's been
people like me deciding what patients
need to have and then we get that to
them and then we try to push them to do
what we what we think they should
and it hasn't fit into the fabric of
people's lives so you know one of the
ways one of the challenges that we we've
been thinking about in terms of starting
to deliver tools digitally to people is
in mental health we have lots and lots
of behavioral strategies so we don't we
don't win weight as a you know when
when the person has depression you don't
treat depression you don't say you know
we're gonna fix your depression you you
know ultimately what we're talking about
is little component components of
treatment right so we have behavioral
activation so we try to get people to go
out and do more positive stuff right
we have cognitive restructuring to try
to help people recognize negative
thoughts so we have a goal-setting
problem solving lots of lots of
behavioral strategies and some work for
some people
others work for other people some people
prefer some so how do you structure that
and and then at the same time you know
increasingly we have lots of different
features in the technology right so just
for apps you know you've got texts
you've got video you've got audio you
got messaging you can do tracking you
can you you know you can do logging
feedback you can there's all kinds of
different ways that people interact some
people like blogging things some people
hate logging things you know it's so-so
so you start to you can see here that if
we're gonna design something that's
gonna help the vast majority people
you're gonna be filling in a grid here
that's gonna be enormous and how do you
design a system that is going to meet
people with the interaction styles that
they prefer and the kind of the
behavioral strategies and so what we've
what we've started to do is to say you
know there isn't we can't develop an app
for this what what we can do you know
what what the way that people use apps
or tools right now is that the little
component parts you don't use an app to
manage your entire life you use an app
to find a restaurant using a map to map
it there use an app to book your you
know to manager your your plane flight
to you know you have little apps that do
little things right and so what we've
done is created a suite of apps kind of
this is just sort of a representation
that we call in telecare it's 13 or 14
apps and each one is just a single
behavioral strategy and a single
interaction style and and you know and
so the the goal is to get something that
is for the most part can be used pretty
quickly people can open it they can use
it and and then they're done with it and
then there's one app that we call the
hub app that if people download that
it organized it organizes their
interaction with the whole suite all
right so it's just breaking it down into
the component parts so they can be
flexibly applied to people as needed
everybody with me okay so this is just
an example so day-to-day I'll give you
some examples these are all up on on
google play and that we I think the
first three or four of them are up on
iOS so day-to-day is is more didactic
kind of like those old ones so this is
it'll it'll give a brief sort of
didactic explanation each week and then
give reminders sort of messages every
day to kind of keep people reminded of
that that sort of lesson right so this
is kind of traditional this is sort of a
traditional thought challenge or thing
so you go in you can use you know check
your you can identify a negative thought
and then find a way of challenging it
but then there are others like daily
feats is is is really pretty simple you
get in you you peg your level of
depression if you're really depressed
you start at level one and I got out of
bed I grew myself I made good food
choices or I ate something and I went
outside that's it and you check those
off each day four or five times in a row
and then you level up to level two and
you get another set you can add some in
if you want takes 10 seconds that's it
this this app has actually been the the
most popular app because it's so simple
and so I thought I thought nobody's ever
gonna use this you know when it was one
of my developers thought it up and this
is this one gets used more than any any
of them because it's simple this one
uses images a little bit more so you can
take a photo at a mantra to it and it
loads and it reminds you of that mantra
periodically that's all it does so
there's a lot of these so we've had
since it over the last two years from
Google Play we've had about 80,000
installs 76,000 unique users and as of a
couple of days ago there were 10,000
10,000 active users meaning that they've
used one of the apps over the last 30
days so it's been working pretty well if
we look at a benchmark one benchmark
that's been used for health apps is you
know most people download
and you maybe open it once and never
look at it again so for this was a diet
app and 2.6 percent of people used it
more than 10 times so buy that around
five to thirty five percent of our of
the people that have downloaded a
Nutella care app have have met that
criterion so you can see here you know
across all the apps on average they're
used about 13 times over the course of a
month the daily feats are our top one is
you know use twenty seven times over
forty five days on average day to day
over thirty eight days and then all the
way down here to see this one is so much
of a dog we've pulled it off we've been
able to fix it
so some of these others here or not you
know our need need more help and I
should also say we've been iterating
over these after we put them up there we
long you know we we got feedback we get
people to give us feedback and we made
changes until we ran out of money and
and now they're up there the way they
are so we also have done a trial this is
we've done two trials now I'll talk
about the first one the second one we're
just we're just starting to analyze the
data so this is just the first field
trial with a hundred people and so this
was starting to look at how do you put
this into into into a care system with
coaching and so you know we enrolled
ninety nine people who had the pH Q as a
measure of depression and the gid is a
measure of anxiety so these are people
with elevated levels levels of
depression or anxiety where a physician
would refer them for treatment and so
this is the dashboard and there's this
this here is the apps when they've been
used and launched and if the the care
manager clicks on it gives them a little
bit of information
this is manages the the the text
messaging this is the apps that are
installed and the apps that are being
used and then this is their sort of
history of symptom severity so this is
all that the coaches get and they had a
30-minute phone call with people to get
started and then over the eight weeks
they just use text messaging back and
forth and so this is the reduction in
depression and anxiety that we saw so
it's a substantial viewed another way
for the
and everybody started out blue so they
all were they all had significant levels
of depression and at the end of the
eight weeks 37 percent had no symptoms
of depression at all anymore
40 percent had had had dropped below the
threshold they still had some residual
symptoms and 22 percent still had
symptoms that needed treatment so these
are these are good these are good
findings we were we were pleased with
this and we've we've currently just
finished a randomized trial and the
outcomes are looking very very similar
so so how might how might this work why
why might this be working well I mean at
a simple level people are using the apps
so maybe that's helping and they're
getting coaching so those are the two
pieces here so let's look at let's look
at the let's look at the app news so the
average app launch is over eight weeks
we're a hundred and ninety five app
launches and if you know if you if
you're familiar with kind of that's a
lot that and and typically when you what
person over eight weeks yeah and and
just in those just in those eight weeks
and when you look at app use for these
interventions typically you get kind of
a hockey stick right you get people they
start off using it and then in the first
week or two they drop off and it gets
low here what we see is people are
consistently using three or four uses
launching the apps three or four times a
day throughout the entire trial and in
fact two-thirds of them continued to use
them after the after the trial ended and
so I think the the reason that that we
see that there's there's one is that the
average time that takes is a minute and
the median is 17 seconds so we have you
know we have a bunch of apps that are
like the checklist that just they just
take a few seconds to use they're simple
and then there's a couple that are
longer like there's some relaxation so
that takes you know five minutes ten
minutes with depending on the video but
but in general they're simple to use so
they can fit easily into the fabric of
people's lives the other I think is that
the the idea and I hadn't thought about
this when we designed it but
people are getting new apps they use the
apps for a couple a week or two and then
they use another one and so it's not
like staying with the same app there's
novelty involved and so they're not
necessarily getting sick of doing the
same thing over and over again so then I
want to talk you know go back and talk
about use so we you've already seen
these data this is from the public
deployment so this is this is fresh data
so it's you know it's not exactly
comparable but you can see here that
that you know for the apps these are the
the mean here is 27 in the in the with
the coaching it was a median of 29 so I
don't know it's not exactly the same
metric but it's sort of in this you can
see this is in the same ballpark right
so the use of the use patterns once
somebody has it on their phone the use
pattern within any individual app is
kind of the same which is surprising so
the coaches aren't necessarily getting
once that once the apps on their phone
the coaches aren't really getting them
to use it more necessarily but what you
see here up here is that people are
using more of the apps the coach is
really you know able to get them you get
them to use more of the apps I think
2:30 in the public deployment 2/3 of the
people only use one app and one-third
then start using a number of them and
it's mostly the people who download the
The Hub app who end up using more of
them because they get recommendations so
so recommendations maybe increase app
use and this is this is just the data
from the the first the people with the
hub app on their phone and that they get
they get they end up for these different
apps they end up you know if a
recommendation automatically has
launched it increases the likelihood
that they're gonna use that app by this
this amount yeah it all goes through the
hub and so the hub I thank you for
asking that so what the hub does is it
monitors what's on the phone and then it
will make a recommendation at each week
it will recommend a new app initially
initially we just did it randomly
and we've recently put in a just a
commodity recommender engine that
increases the said you know they didn't
you I'll show you it increases it
slightly but we think that where we're
going with this is if we think if we can
start to learn how to recommend it we
can start to increase you know increase
the helpfulness of those recommendations
at the end say no there's no good reason
for why we did it that was honestly I
think we were just trying to figure out
how to get this out and launched so we
didn't have you know we we had the hub
app do a number of things at once that's
on once the hub app is on on the phone
it manages the the recommendations it
then manages all the notifications so
it's kind of everything then goes
through the goes through the hub app it
also I think it's probably neat in in
dire need of some redesign because it's
the thing that's that people complain
about the most so it's not it's not the
best way to do it
so but along those lines when we look at
the these apps they you know looking at
app use they fall into clusters so
people who use day-to-day or I cope or
my mantra they you know if you use one
of those they're more likely to use
others right and they fall into I think
they four of these seem to make sense so
you know the first column there is
language or they use sort of common
seems like they're engaging people
cognitively so it's sort of a
psychological method of engagement the
second one the purple chill is the
relaxation app and slumber time is sleep
helps people with insomnia so kind of
relaxation apps then check apps that
rely on checklists so that's more kind
of interaction style that that seems to
be holding it together activity boost me
is is kind of behavioral activation so
getting people to do more positive
activities move me is getting people to
do more physical activity so those kind
of hang together so these make sense and
then these are just the worst apps that
we have and I'm not sure
I'm not I'm not sure analytically what's
happening but there are junky app so so
you know you can see that I think we can
we you know we can start thinking about
having a recommender engine that can
drive you know essentially be kind of a
Netflix for for mental health apps that
can start you know directing people to
apps that they're more likely to use and
we're so we're doing this in the context
of in telecare right now so we're
working with some people at it at
Columbus you know some biostatisticians
and machine learning people at Columbia
are doing the analytics to try to
develop a better system for this but you
can also imagine that this this kind of
analytic system could be used for any
apps they don't necessarily have to just
be ours but you can start to have you
know a platform that can begin to
provide you know guidance to people for
the I don't know how many hundreds or
thousands of mental health apps that are
out there on the App Store's so that's
kind of one direction that we're going
with you know with the design here so
you know maybe we don't really need care
managers if we can get people to use the
apps right and I I still think we do and
there's two there's two reasons one is I
don't think health care settings are
going to want to host apps as a form of
treatment they're in the business of
providing services so you know and I
think so I think that we have to start
thinking about how we can use digital
technologies to improve their ability to
extend services and then the other is
that that I think you know I think we
still in the work that we've done we
have some bias samples right we're
recruiting people who want to come in
and be part of a study these aren't your
average patients these are people that
just the fact that they're in our study
they've they've already demonstrated
that they're more motivated than the
average person that's pretty different
than having a care manager say I think
you should do X Y or Z that's gonna be
that you're gonna get a whole different
level of people we know that we know
that you know patients 50% of patients
don't even take the medications that
their doctors recommend them so so you
know we're dealing with I think I think
there's still a huge role for for care
management even though even though it
looks like we're doing well so you know
I described the
coaching that we did 30 to 40 minutes of
call time 28:25 text messages and when
we look at the text messages there's
they they fall into like 10 or 15
different buckets when we when we
cluster them one is opinions about the
apps I like this I don't like it picking
which app to use making a decision
technical problems sorry responding the
coach sorry I didn't get back to you
both wha excuses scheduling etc things
are going well yes no and thank you
right these are pretty these are so so
these are pretty well-defined buckets
and so when we start looking it at you
know these the coaching a lot of this
could be automated I think I don't think
care systems at this point are ready to
turn it all over to something that's
automated but you know and you'll see in
a minute I think I think providing
automation can really help care managers
because care managers in these systems
are not necessarily trained in managing
mental health problems yeah III think I
think we will so we in these early
studies we screen people out with
significant suicidality there are people
who are have some suicidality so they
certainly having suicidal ideation as
part of it and we do get some people who
talk about those you know who will raise
it we have it we did not have any of
those hundred people say I'm gonna go
out and kill myself which does happen in
some of my studies but so then we call
them up and we usually talk with them
and assess them just in general not
suicidal just you know I'm having so
much stress about my job tomorrow not
suicidal bit just need more help as far
as doing the things I hear calls for
help in that sense yeah I mean part of
so you know part what I haven't
presented here was kind of the
development of our of our care
management model and and we also didn't
get that right first so you know when we
started out that you know
we were going through and talking to the
users and the care managers there was a
lot of lack of clarity of what the role
of the care manager was so one of the
things that we had to do is is make that
pretty explicit upfront that this is not
therapy
and so the still people brought up
things like you know you know a death in
the family or you know significant is
significant stressors that that and so
you know when those came up if it was
significant enough the they could
arrange for a second call to talk with
them for a few minutes to try to connect
them with other services that might be
more appropriate or like like that they
didn't they didn't get into so but the
care managers did not get into helping
people solve specific problems they
didn't go over the line and to starting
to do the psychotherapy and that the
reason for that I think is that you know
we're anticipating that the kind of
people that would would manage a system
like this care managers typically don't
have a lot of mental health training so
you're going to need a system that can
kind of have a defined set of goals for
those for those managers does that kind
of answer your are those a lot less than
these you know I I would have to go back
so these we just got from from somebody
that did our NLP at University of
Washington yesterday so I put these in
last night so so I don't I don't know
what I don't actually know what happened
to those those sort of random ones that
didn't fit in
how many we're so sorry but yeah there
are it but I think that that's you know
one that we anticipate kind of how a
system like this might work you know
what I anticipate is I I don't think in
a care system right now they would be
comfortable with any kind of message
going out to a patient that hadn't been
vetted by human I I think that means in
any kind of care setting maybe we'll get
there but I think most care set care
environments right now that that's
that's a step too far but I think what
we can do is is give care managers send
this message have them look at it and
send it
and then have you know the ones that are
like you're describing that there isn't
an automatic response you know here's
something here are three different
levels or here you know here are three
different types of responses you might
give or you know contact somebody for
further assistance on this but but
essentially guiding providing in the
same way that we're giving patients
trying to give patients guidance I think
we have to give the care managers care
managers guidance turn off the bat they
have to give us a rating on how suicidal
they feel and if it goes over a certain
number we have the trigger like we know
exactly what their response should be
like all much yeah you're dealing with a
population there that is really very
suicidal so we have to be we're always
dealing with suicidality in the context
the primary care has been that has been
you know each organization we have to we
have to negotiate that differently
because they you know obviously when you
go into primary care in primary care
sort of medical settings they you know
nobody wants their patients to commit
suicide but but they you know physicians
want they they don't they don't they
don't have time what they need is this
is what you need to do here's a yes/no
this person is suicidal you need to you
need to refer them you need to get them
help this person is not you know that
and and it's really difficult in these
systems to get that level of clarity so
we end up for example you know when we
were working with northern northwestern
one of the outpatient clinics in
northwestern we didn't assess it they
did not want to assess suicide now they
were worried about liability so we
screened them out we assessed it right
at the beginning and we just screen
people out who had high levels of
suicidality other places they do want
that information and they have somebody
tasked with you know who can do that
outreach so it's really I mean again
this is where I think you know a
one-size-fits-all system is not going to
work in our care system and when you see
when you see one care system you've seen
one care system and there's a lot that
doesn't translate to other care systems
so I think these kinds of tools are
going to have to be adaptable to the
needs of the the individual systems
so you know what we've done and speaking
of that what we started doing is is you
know think realizing what we have to do
if we if we're starting to think about
designing tools to go into a care system
we have to design for the patients
obviously we have to design for whoever
is going to manage it but we also have
to design and understand the care system
so we've started we've just now starting
to work with three different care
systems one is North Western medicine
physician Partners which is a an arm of
North Western medicine that is building
out its value-based care so they take
essentially like you know Blue Cross
Blue Shield contracts they don't they
don't do fee-for-service and they're
buying up practices from Lake Michigan
out to the Mississippi River so they're
they're sort of in this you know
expanding their their their footprint
and they need to be able to manage
mental health problems this is a huge
problem for them because they don't have
capacity and if you get out of the
Greater Chicago area they're just there
is no there aren't any providers and
we've been talking to rush which manages
low income a lot of low-income clinics
around Chicago and then we're talking
with University of Arkansas their
medical care system which manages a
large rural population so we've started
doing some initial design work with you
know Madu ready yeah so we're working
with motto is kind of leading leading up
a lot of that and so I'll just give you
a flavor so we started with North
Western medicine and we you know did a
lot of interviews with people in primary
care clinics and quickly realized it was
never gonna fly there was no way that we
were gonna put this into a primary care
clinic because there's no bandwidth
nobody has time they don't have the
expertise so it you know that's where
the patients are but there's no staff
that can manage it and what we realized
is that there's there you know this
organization a lot of organizations are
developing these sort of centralized
care systems and North Western medicine
is so it's a central centralized care
management system where they're getting
you know when physicians make referrals
they're making sure that patients get
there so they'll call them up they'll
work with them and they have problem
patients they'll stay engage with them
to try to make sure they get the care
that they need so these are these are
people that are delivering their care
remotely and they're often dealing with
patients that are kind of difficult or
that have problem
so we realized that's probably the place
so we've started we've done a you know a
first round of detailed yeah first round
of interviews with with these care
managers and you know we found a number
of barriers problems so you know they
don't see their role as managing mental
mental health necessarily they manage
medical problems and lifestyle problems
obesity and so on but they haven't seen
mental health as part of their what they
do it's well honestly they don't really
know what their role is because they're
developing it and it's kind of a chaotic
system but they also most of them have
no training in mental health but on the
plus side more than half of their
patients when we go into the medical
records more than half of their patients
have significant levels of depression so
this is this is this is a population
where that's a huge problem and they
recognize that the depression interferes
with their ability to get other things
done so if they have diabetes they know
that the one the people that are
depressed at a harder time managing
their diabetes if it's so they recognize
it as a problem there are there's a lot
of barriers to mental health referral so
either long waits or just lack of
availability and they see that they
actually see this type of system is
potentially beneficial so rather than
going into a primary care where we have
to find somebody and tell them to do
something in addition to what they're
already doing here we could potentially
develop a system that can make their
jobs easier and if we can develop a
system that makes somebody's job easier
it is much more likely to be implemented
in a sustainable in a sustainable manner
so so far in this setting there they're
very they're very enthusiastic and we're
starting to do the same work with Rush
and with and with with with the
University of Arkansas Medical Center so
so that's kind of I think yeah ok so ok
so briefly so I think what we're looking
at here is you know the primary care is
still the doc is still the primary
person that is connected to the patient
you know specialty mental health may or
may not be available but we now
increasingly have these care managers
if we can put something in the center
there that can manage communications
between those that can monitor the help
monitor the patient that can provide
support and can can you know we may be
able to get something that actually is
sustainable and workable I'm gonna skip
through this this is sort of the this is
the summary but I in interest of time I
want to get to I want to get to some of
the sensing stuff because I wanted to
talk with some of the people here about
that and and just briefly you know I
mean you can think about these these
these digital mental health tools you
know particularly the skills-based ones
as little feedback devices right so they
get information in they process it and
they provide that information back to
the user in some way that's hopefully
useful to them provide some insights and
motivation right and the problem that
that a lot of users encounter is putting
the information in right we've all
probably downloaded apps that we think
is gonna be great and then we use them
for a few days and get sick in or
anything the information and uninstall
it right so that's that's where you know
potentially having some way of acquiring
those data like you know in the same way
that we can get step counters now if
made you know have made a big impact on
people who want to be physically active
it may be helpful so just a little bit
of the work that we've done this is when
we started a few years ago we you know
developed an app purple robot they could
pull the sensor data off of you know off
of Android phones and this is our first
you know mostly it was we did this to
try to debug the software but we
enrolled about 30 people and and you
know there was a pretty good range of
depression and so this is two weeks of
data and these are some clusters from
GPS that we got so I mean some some some
features from GPS features and so you
see here location variants the the
variety of places a person goes was
pretty strongly related to their level
of depression
so people who tend to go to the same
place all the time are more likely to be
depressed but novelty people are less
likely to be depressed entropy if you if
in the if you go to if you spend more
time if your time is distributed
across places that you know more evenly
your more less likely to be depressed if
you tend to spend all of your time most
of your time at home or at work like he
says home stay there you're more likely
to be depressed and the one that I was
particularly interested in here is
circadian circadian movement so this is
you know people who tend to be more
rhythmic in their movement through
Geographic space they were they were
they were less likely to be depressed so
it seemed that mood would pull people
off so this was interesting so we
thought you know you know could be just
chance so we got another data set from
from Andrew Campbell who had collected
the student life data set and ran the
same analyses so these were stood about
50 students who you know they had they
got we got there they got their phq-9
the measure of depression that the
beginning of the semester at the end of
ten weeks and then collected their GPS
data over those ten weeks and what you
see here is a baseline the number of
places that they went location variance
and circadian movement were significant
not as not as high as in the first
sample but they still remain significant
and then at the end there was a pretty
broad correlation you know pretty a lot
of different GPS features were related
so the general idea that movement
through space was related to depression
seems to be seems to be can you know
confirmed yeah they went to school they
just say these were these were students
at the beginning of their quarter and at
the end of the quarter we didn't have
them do anything or Andrew didn't have
them do anything it's just regular life
so we looked at so one of the things I
don't have a slide on this one of the
things that we I wondered is if you know
if this is really true then then
probably we would see stronger effect on
weekends because they're the you know
during the week their movement is is
less under their own control they have
to go to class they have to do this or
that
on the weekends they're free and indeed
we saw for a number of these features
they were stronger on the weekends you
know another thing we looked at was if
at the baseline depression
does that predict movement so if you
know how depressed I am today does that
tell you anything about how I'm gonna
move through Geographic space next week
five weeks from now ten weeks from now
and it's largely what we would have
expected so you know at the same
measurements taken at the same time
there was sort of a modest correlation
and that all went towards zero as time
went on and then we looked at it the
other way so the GPS features predicting
depression ten weeks later and what we
were surprised to see I was actually was
surprised that there's no change
so how people move through Geographic
space tells you just about as much about
how depressed I am today as it does
about how depressed I'm going to be in
in in in in ten weeks and another slide
I don't have I should have had is that
the amount of change in depression and
these people went up and down so there's
a lot of movement in this in this sample
and they are not their students they're
not necessarily all mentally doing fine
so so what this suggests here is that
you know that how we move through
Geographic space may may be may be an
early warning detector for depression
before people start having symptoms one
of the things we might see is social
withdrawal or changes in patterns of
movement
at the same time right we published our
first article fortunately my chrome
Musel se was doing the same thing at UCL
in London and found kind of similar
features we were fortunately the one
time in my life I actually didn't get
scooped we've got published a month
before he did there's another group in
in in in Oxford that did the same kind
of thing these are actually using our
features and they did it with bipolar
patients and they can predict depression
so this is you know this is looking good
so we got our first study then we
replicated it now we've got you know
independent people so we you know did
another study that we where we got 211
people from around the country in
different people we collected the
collected this over the space they were
enrolled for six weeks and we got their
depression at the beginning at the end
and a bunch of tracked a bunch of
different stuff
and it got nothing and it was really it
was you know so we thought well maybe
it's you know this was done over the
winter maybe you know maybe it's you
know going out doors in in in
Minneapolis and December is different
than in Miami maybe we had a broader
range of people older people move
differently than younger people we
looked at a lot of this stuff looked
like younger people we got an effect but
a lot of this we just got no no
significance and and you know it is was
very disappointing but yeah these people
so that you have some sort of baseline
of not impress people because you're
right it's really different from it
warmly well we did have we did have so
this I should say this group was roughly
divided into quarters so one quarter was
had high depression and high anxiety one
quarter had high depression and no
anxiety one had a anxiety and depression
and it was one quarter that when the
healthy controls we just didn't see
anything
and I I think I I i don't think this we
did not we we looked at I mean there's
probably ways that we can do this to try
to look at this more carefully there's a
lot of issues in here I don't
necessarily believe this is the the
final story but I think what this does
is what this the message I think that
I'm getting from this is that this is a
much more complicated issue than we
thought initially so the other studies
are small they tend to be geographically
defined in a small area you know an aero
scope of people and you know I'll talk
about this in a moment talking about it
now you know I think what we're dealing
with is just an enormous amount of
variability that you have to manage that
you've got differences in how people use
their phones in weather in you know
health in
age and I mean just just just a huge
amount of variability that you know any
small study I mean all these studies are
10 or 30 people mostly done with
students you know the the and CS
students probably not general students
you know so so the you know when you
move this out and a lot of the studies
also you know I think that part of that
is that in CSU you know you to get
published you have to do something that
nobody's done before and so it's not you
know replicability is not that's not
that's not highly prized but but in
public health we have to have things
that you can replicate and so you know I
think I think there's there's a lot of
room that where we can work together in
this but but it's not gonna be simple so
I think we're almost out of time so I'm
just gonna kind of wrap up and what
we're doing here is what were what we're
doing now is we just got another grant
funded to extend this and we're started
to extend this work and we're partnering
also now with UCLA so UCLA has a large
project that they're starting called the
depression Grand Challenge so they are
their goal is to enroll a hundred
thousand people and track them over over
10 to 15 years with everything genetics
all kinds of stuff because they want to
solve the problem of depression that's
that's the goal and this is kind of at
the highest level of the university that
they've made this this initiative and so
we're working with them to try to start
doing this kind of sensing you know to
get this sensing in so over the next
year or two they're planning on
enrolling around 10,000 people and we're
gonna try to get this is the the you
know get at least for a large segment of
those people get software on their
phones where we can pull the data off so
that's that that's kind of the direction
we're going and I think that I think to
solve these products of problems that's
what we're gonna need to do is just also
say that what we did get out of this are
things like we could we could in this
sample of 10 we could see when people
woke up and when they when they went to
bed and when they got up within a
10-minute window and we could get that
with around ninety percent accuracy we
could get the relationship to their
contact so was it a friend a family
member
you know - because how you text and
phone is is different with those
different categories we could define we
could predict that so so I think that
you know there are things that we can
predict more reliably and I think those
are gonna be behavioral behaviors that
are more proximal to the phone sensors
like if there's a direct line from the
sensor to the behavior it's probably
gonna be easier or more more reliably
detectable if you get things like
depression which is vague and you know
expressed very differently across people
it's gonna be a lot harder to get
reliable detection so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna end it here so just say thank you
to a lot of people because this wasn't
just my work this is a lot of people so
thank you very much
[Applause]
closest to home and closest to work now
went both ways it's like if you loved
work and it was a super good predictor
of me not being oppressed hated your job
but so we saw some location-based
information - yeah I think there's
something there you know it's
interesting because I don't think we've
ever been able to really track it that
well before there was a guy there's a so
I've sort of started looking at you know
some geographers have used this and
there's there's a there's a guy in
Israel I'm trying to remember his name
no I can dig it up anyway he's so he's
been funded like by the various the
Israeli tourist board and the Italian
tourist board to use so sensing - for
all kinds of thing but he's interested
in mood and so he had this great study
in in in Jerusalem where they got like
5,000 tourists and they were collecting
their GPS data they I think they they
got some kind of GSR sensor you know
like a wrist-worn sensor and then they
got their mood and he created the mood
map of Jerusalem and it's like you know
you can see like elevations that are
reflected across all of these as people
get close to the Wailing Wall and
it's just it's just really amazing how
like the geography of that city can Matt
you know can can impact people's moods
and I so I think there's a lot that we
can you know we can learn people's
rhythms are reflected in it that's other
questions or comments or critiques so
when you say you talk about the
collecting sensor data on the phones is
that specifically about location but
going forward do you have but we've
we've collected one we collected in that
last study it wasn't just GPS certainly
call em use is not on Android so we got
call you know call and text logs light
so like the the the the the the
wake-sleep wake you time was a big
factor you can get a lot just knowing
when people go to bed the first time
because people are fairly consistent but
you know also like sound light was a
factor use of the phone so we had a
bunch of them we did not get
accelerometry because that just burns up
the battery we and you know we're we're
trying other little things like you know
maybe you know maybe if we can turn all
the sensors on for like you know 30
seconds periodically during the day that
will give us a sort of a burst of data
that would be useful I don't know but
those are the kinds of things that it
might be helpful to talk with you about
because you thinking about these things
[Applause]
you